I believe in democracy and liberty that
you can not,
you can not talk in the name of any
people without elections.
And you cannot supervise the people in
that says,
Eh,
you,
I am not in.
Nobody has the roid eh,
to,
to say what is good and bad for the
Egyptian people.
They must,
uh,
truth for themselves.
Uh,
that is a very,
very strong idea in the west.
That free elections means in the other
boards.
Phonetics in public.
And this is not true in Egypt is not
true.
First.
Second,
I think that we must respect the choice
of the people.
And third,
Egypt has,
uh,
its first democratic,
experience,
uh,
in the,
about that in the 19th century.
So I mean,
we are not beginning from zero.
We have our own experience.
And as you say,
you have,
uh,
it's,
it's at risk that you'll have terrible
people coming be,
could be elected any moment there.
But what is very important is how to be
able to defend the who own a democratic
procedure.
And the,
this,
this could be done easily.
Uh,
so I see no point are to support Arab
dictators.
You see and claiming that,
uh,
they are the only choice because,
and I would say even a,
the country,
I would say that because of the Arab
dictators,
we are having much more,
uh,
people going to becoming phonetics
everyday because,
uh,
the WHO would that be?
The young generations are not,
uh,
allowed to express themselves
politically because the dictatorship
means a total failure in,
in every domain.
So you'll have more and more desperate
people who could be a turning to a
phonetic people at any moment.
So I think that,
that the real solution for the whole
outer world is a year at the moment.